[MUSIC]
You're so busy running and
competing for meetings and
time that the ability to stop and
pause and recharge your batteries and
think broader and much deeper was
really a terrific opportunity.
What I took from SCP and
what I think I'm doing differently is
consciously thinking about not
only what I need to do today, but
how that bridge is to where business
goes in the future as well.
One of the highlights of
coming to Stanford was it is
right in the middle of
the technology corridor.
To be right in the heart of The Silicon
Valley, I think, is a huge benefit.
To think differently to,
how to be more open to the ideas and
concepts and to really define how we serve
customers in a differentiated way is
really a great part of being right here.
SEP, I consider it an incredible
investment in me as a lead.
Think about the incredible
investment my family made.
Because in the middle of summer
your kids are out of school.
How do I balance all that?
And I would say, make the time,
because you have so
much more to give back to others.
One of the really key benefits of
the program is building a global network
that enables you to think differently,
not only about what we do here in
the U.S., but around the world as well.
Coaching and developing and
sending talent to programs such as SEP
really enables companies to maintain
relevancy, maintain a competitive edge,
and maintain a leadership position.
Don't be the person who has all
the answers but rather be the leader who
facilitates different kind of conversation
as a result of what you've learned.
Our credo, which is what we live by,
says our best was good for
today, tomorrow we will do better.
The investment Verizon made for me to
attend SEP has made me a better leader,
and in return I believe I make
the business better every day.
I really believe that SEP was
transformational, because it gave me
a platform on which to think about
the business differently, and in thinking
about the business differently, to deliver
different kind of performance results.
It will be the best
investment you've ever made.
[SOUND]